SHAWN SIMISTER: All right.
Thank you everyone for coming
out today and welcome to the
Freebase APIs, Tapping into
Google's Knowledge Graph.
Before I get started, my
name is Shawn Simister.
I work in Developer Relations
with the Knowledge Group which
includes Search and the
Knowledge Graph.
And I work on Freebase, the
Freebase APIs, Schema.org, and
some of our search APIs.
So you've heard a lot over the
last couple days about the
Knowledge Graph, but I want to
take a little bit of time at
the beginning of this talk to
talk about what really is a
Knowledge Graph.
What does it mean to have
a Knowledge Graph?
And how are we using
that at Google?
And how can you use that
in your application?
So at the very basics,
a graph has entities.
In the Knowledge Graph they're
real world entities, so
people, places, things,
organizations.
In this case, I have an entity
here for Daft Punk.
And those form the nodes
in the graph.
And the nodes, as you can see in
this diagram, are connected
by edges and those edges are
labeled edges that represent
the relationships between these
real world entities.
So in this case, Daft Punk, the
band, actually appeared in
"Tron Legacy", the movie.
And so we have billions of
those relationships in
Google's Knowledge Graph,
hundreds of millions of those
real world entities, and
that's what forms the
Knowledge Graph.
But more than that, each of
these nodes is typed.
So we know that Daft
Punk is a band.
And we know that "Tron
Legacy" is a movie.
And we know that there are
certain relationships like
appears in that appear between a
band and a movie or a person
and a movie.
And because it's a graph
shape, there's no fixed
structure to this.
You can add as many
connections.
So Daft Punk came from Paris.
Their record label is
Virgin Records.
And it just fans
out from there.
And that's how we have so many
hundreds of millions of
entities now in the Knowledge
Graph as you can see here.
So this is just a little
snapshot of how the Knowledge
Graph is built.
Every single one of those
hundreds of millions of
entities has a unique
identifier, which lets us
treat entities with the same
name differently within the
Knowledge Graph.
You've probably seen that when
you do a Google search for
something like Boston.
And it'll ask you do you want
to disambiguate between the
band or the city.
And so we'll see in the Freebase
APIs how you can use
those unique identifiers in
your application to access
structured data, both these
real world entities, and
importantly, the real world
entities that your users care
about, the entities that are
important to your application.
So I've mentioned a couple
things about Freebase but let
me give you the high
level overview.
Freebase is a Knowledge Graph.
It's an open Knowledge Graph,
open to everyone to use.
If you have a Google account,
which I'm sure you do, you can
log into Freebase.com
right now.
You can see we have
40 million topics.
So a little bit smaller than
Google's Knowledge Graph, but
it's really densely populated
with over a
billion facts in there.
And a lot of the entities are
things that you would expect
to see in Wikipedia.
In fact, we pulled a lot
of data from Wikipedia.
So there are those really
notable people, places, and
things, again, that matter to
the users of your application.
We've also categorized
them by 2,000 types.
So remember, I said every node
in that graph can have a type.
In fact, in Freebase, in the
Knowledge Graph they can have
multiple types.
So if you go again to
Freebase.come you can see a
listing of all the different
categories of types we have
from those 2,000 types.
Now, the reason you're
here today is
because of our free API.
So anyone who goes through the
Developer Console can sign up
for the Freebase API.
You can use it for commercial
purposes as long as you give
us some attribution.
You can get 10,000
requests a day.
It's really quite easy to use,
as I'll show you in a second.
But if you need more than that,
or if you want to do
some really heavy graph
algorithms or analysis on the
graph, we provide the entire
graph, all one billion facts,
40 million entities,
as a data dump.
So you can download the entire
graph to your hard drive and
do with it as you'd like.
Most importantly, Freebase is
one of the really important
sources for Google's
Knowledge Graph.
And so if you contribute to
Freebase and your edits are
trustworthy and meet our
criteria, they could end up in
Google's Knowledge Graph
and in Search.
So every one of those 40 million
real world entities in
Freebase has a page that looks
like this in Freebase.
We just recently redesigned
this.
It's running on App Engine.
It's a really cool new site.
There's a lot more than I can
show on this one page, but you
can see down the right side we
have all the types that apply
to this node in the graph.
And if you click those, you can
kind of jump down the page
and see all the entries in our
graph, all the properties that
have been assigned to it.
And if you don't see what you're
expecting to see there,
you can add it or edit
it yourself.
You might notice up in the top
right hand corner, there's
little drop down box there for
English, we're translating
Freebase and the Knowledge
Graph into
many different languages.
I think Freebase is targeting
about 40 languages right now.
And so we're pulling in data
from all the different
languages of Wikipedia.
And so if you go to Daft Punk,
you can actually get
information in English or French
or German or whatever
language you're looking for,
all using that same unique
identifier.
You'll notice underneath, we
have a couple tabs here.
So Properties is the one
I just explained.
I18N, internationalization, is
those international names that
I just explained.
So if you go to that tab,
you'll see for any given
language what name we've
assigned to it.
And we do some interesting
stuff to decide when an
English name should be shown
in another language.
The next tab is Keys.
So these are-- you can think of
in database terms-- these
are foreign keys into
other databases.
So this is the unique part of
the URL that will tell you
which Wikipedia page corresponds
to this entity, or
which Twitter account
corresponds to this entity, or
which Google+ page corresponds
to this entity.
And lastly, Links are just all
those edges in the graph,
those one billion connections
between the real world
entities and the Freebase
Knowledge Graph.
And so if you really want to
dig into it and figure out
what's going on, what connects
to this specific node in the
graph, you'd go to the Links
page and you'll just see a
huge long list of them.
There's a very cool thing
up here at the top.
You see it says, View
Specific Properties.
It's kind of like the Awesome
Bar in Firefox.
You can just start typing in
types or properties and it'll
start filtering down
that list of links.
So it's a pretty cool feature.
And I encourage you to go check
it out after the talk.
But today, we're going to be
talking about a couple
specific ways that you can use
the Freebase APIs to add more
search, add more semantics
to your application.
These are some of the things
that you're already seeing
Google doing with Search and
with other Google products.
But because there are so many
similarities between how
Freebase is built and how the
Knowledge Graph is built, you
can do a lot of the same things
that we're doing in
Search in your own application
with the Freebase APIs.
So I'll start off with
Autosuggest, which is just
suggesting entities.
Semantic Tagging, which lets
you add entities to your
content, Entity Collections,
which I think you've seen in
Search at the top when
you do a search
for like Zombie movies.
Geosearch, which is looking
for entities
but based on location.
And lastly, Topical Web Links,
which is finding other sources
on the web like that Twitter
page or the Google+ page for
that specific entity.
So the first example I want to
show you is Autosuggest.
This is something that's been
really important to Freebase
from the beginning.
It's the ability to
turn strings into
things, as we say.
And that's really just
a way of saying we
take ambiguous keywords--
in this case, house.
So if you typed house into a
search box, you don't know if
we're talking about the TV show
or the music genre or
maybe something like
the White House.
And so the Freebase Suggest
widget is a way that you
disambiguate those entities and
turn it into one of those
unique identifiers for
a node in the graph.
And once you have that unique
identifiers, you'll see from
the following samples, all the
kind of cool stuff that you
can do with that.
Let me just connect
to the internet.
There we go.
All right.
So in the first box here, say
I have a form I want someone
to enter a music group.
So you can just start typing
and all of a sudden you see
I'm suggesting possible
music groups.
I'm using the Freebase graph,
those 40 million entities, to
suggest plausible real world
entities that begin
with the word Daft.
There's actually quite
a few musical groups.
You'll notice not all of these
have Daft in the name, but we
also look at their Wikipedia
page or things like that to
figure out what entities are
related to them and rank some
of the suggestions
that way as well.
You'll see now if I just click
on one of those suggestions,
this is jQuery widget and so
in my JavaScript I get back
this data, not just the name
of the entity that I've
selected, but also the important
MID, that's the
machine ID that we use in
Freebase for uniquely
identifying all of those
40 million real world
entities in the Graph.
So this is a really easy way,
not only to disambiguate
things in your application, but
also to get those strong
identifiers that let you do
other cool things with the
Freebase APIs.
And it's really easy
to customize.
You could see this other example
I have here, exact
same code but I've changed it,
so instead it's just filtering
down to movies.
If I type in Daft there, you'll
see movies related to
Daft Punk, rather than
Daft Punk the band.
And again, if I click on
that, I get the ID.
You'll see there's a score in
there, and we'll get to that
later, but that's basically this
is a search function and
its returning a score for
each entity that was
returned in the list.
So that Autosuggest feature
that you saw is a jQuery
plug-in that you can
add to any page.
It's under a BSD license.
You could extend it if you'd
like, but it's built on top of
our search API.
And so underneath the covers,
this is all that's going on.
This is just a GET request to
the server, we're passing in
whatever text you've
typed so far.
And we also have this filtering
syntax that lets you
say match all of the following
constraints.
It must have this
Freebase type.
You'll remember, if you go back
to the Freebase homepage,
you'll see a big list of those
2,000 types, slash music,
slash musical group is one of
the types of that we organize
entities by.
So if you send that to the
server, this is what you're
going to get back.
In fact, you're going to get
back a much longer version of
this but I couldn't fit
it all on the slide.
But this inner part here with
the MID, the language score,
that's the search result that
gets repeated a number of
times throughout the results.
By default, you get 20 results
back, but there's a query
parameter where you can
extend that as well.
And so using this, we can pass
in little fragments of text to
get back these ranked lists
of entities in Freebase's
Knowledge Graph that
match that keyword.
And then use those MIDs to do
other interesting things in
our application.
And here you can see I've got a
link here in the slide so if
you see the slides after the
talk, you can click through to
the Freebase documentation and
download this jQuery widget
and it really is just one
line of code to add that
Autosuggest functionality to any
input box on an HTML form.
Also, you'll remember I said
this is just a HTTP web
service, so you can call this
functionality from any code.
You can call it from Python or
Java and we have examples in
our documentation, as well, for
how to call that API from
other languages, not just
from JavaScript.
The next example that I want
to show you builds on this
Autosuggest functionality
to do Semantic Tagging.
So imagine you have a whole
bunch of articles of text or
videos or images--
and I don't mean like 10s, I
mean like millions of these--
and you want to categorize
them all.
In fact, our friends at
Wikipedia are doing some
interesting stuff with this.
And so you start to add
tags to the content.
You start to find ways
to categorize it.
And then you have to come
up with a list of tags.
You can't just let people tag it
with anything because then
it gets very messy.
You don't know how
to find things.
And so you can actually use
the data in Freebase as a
vocabulary for tagging
your content.
And that gives you a really
nice list of real world
entities, things that people
are going to care about.
So let me show you
how that works.
So you see I just start typing
and it lets me tag stuff using
entities from the
Knowledge Graph.
In this case, I haven't
constrained it.
It's just searching
all of Freebase.
We get back notable types.
So remember I said any node in
the Graph can have multiple
types assigned to it, but
Freebase will do a little bit
extra for you and figure out
which of those types is the
most descriptive for that entity
so that we can say
things like Jeff Bridges,
the actor or Jeff
Buckley, the singer.
So you can see this
is quite easy.
This is just using another
open source jQuery widget
called Tag-it.
And they support JSONP web
services as a source for tags.
And so you can just take the
Freebase API, plug it right
into that, and auto-complete
on any of these entities in
the Knowledge Graph which saves
you a lot of time with
having to come up with
categories of
tags on your own.
This is just a little snippet of
the code that you'd use in
jQuery Tag-it.
So remember I said you can
plug-in any JSONP web service
and use that as a
source of tags?
So here we have the URL for the
Freebase search API and
we're just telling it to look
at the text that we've typed
in so far, pass it in as the
query parameter, treat it as a
prefix search.
So we want whatever entity we're
looking for to start
with the letters that
we just typed.
And I've limited to six
suggestions in this case, but
you could use more if you had
more room on the screen.
So again, it's more than the one
line of code I just showed
you, but it's not that much
more code to add Semantic
Tagging to any application
using Freebase data.
So the next example I want
to talk about is Entity
Collections.
So far we've just looked at
entities from Freebase's
Knowledge Graph one by one,
looking up an entity by a
keyword or tagging entities one
at a time, but what if we
want to look at the whole
collections of entities?
You know, movies by Jeff
Bridges, rather
than just Jeff Bridges.
So remember I showed you in the
first example when we're
doing Autosuggest, we can
constrain it to just music
groups or just films.
So I'm going to go into a little
bit more detail on the
syntax of that filter
right now.
You can see I have this
filter syntax.
It's in circular brackets.
It starts with All, which
means match all of the
following constraints.
And we only have one constraint
right now, which is
that it has to have a certain
type and that type has to be
slash film slash film which
is Freebase type.
In fact, if you go to
Freebase.com/film/film, you'll
see the definition
for the type.
It's just one more of those
nodes in the Freebase Graph.
Now if I change this, I can do
something like genre action
and you'll see I get a new list
of films and these are
all coming from Freebase,
again.
And so now I've said, find me
all of the entities out of
those 40 million entities that
match two constraints.
They have to be a film
and they have to
have the genre action.
Now you'll notice type starts
with slashes and action is
just a word.
Genre is actually what we call
Metaschema in Freebase.
And so we found that there
were a lot of different
properties in Freebase that all
represented genre, so the
genre of a movie or the
genre of a book.
And so what we did was we
indexed those all under the
same genre Metaschema.
And you can see in that the
documentation we have a whole
list of the Metaschema that
are available to you, just
sort of shortcuts that
help you search for
these things easier.
I can also do contributor and if
I need to do something with
spaces, I just put
it in quotes.
And so now I'm seeing all the
films that have Jeff Bridges,
well not all of them,
but the first seven.
And again, remember I said
that Search API has a
parameter that lets you specify
how many results you
want to get back.
Now again, I'm using Jeff
Bridges the string rather than
an ID like film film.
If I knew that unique MID for
Jeff Bridges, I could plug
that in right here instead and
that would guarantee me that
these are only movies with the
Jeff Bridges who won an Oscar
for Best Actor, not some other
guy named Jeff Bridges.
So let's look at what's
going on in the code.
So again, this is the underlying
Search API.
So you don't need to call it
from jQuery, you don't need to
use JavaScript, you can make
these same sort of collection
queries from whatever
programming language you're
comfortable with.
You can see we're not
even passing in a
keyword query this time.
We're just passing
in the filter.
And so that's kind of the same
as saying the query is
anything, a wild card, but
then applying filter to
everything.
So in this case, I've done a
collection of actors who
starred in the upcoming movie
"The Great Gatsby".
And you see I've used the MID
for "The Great Gatsby" because
there are many films and this
is for the one that's coming
out, I think, this week,
not the older versions.
So there's a lot of different
ways that you can use this to
filter down collections
of entities.
Like I said, there's this
Metaschema that gives you
shortcuts for querying
a lot of different
properties at the same time.
So I've included a couple
links here in the slide.
You can read more about that in
the Freebase documentation.
And there are a lot of examples
about the sort of
things you can do.
Once again, this is the same
sorted JSON data response that
you're used to getting back
from the search API.
So you see an ID, a name, what
it's notable for, and a score.
Remember I said that this
is actually repeated.
So there are many entries with
an MID and a score and a name.
And this is just a little
snippet of JavaScript to show
you how easy it is to do a query
like that in your code.
So here, once again, I'm
calling the Search API
directly from jQuery.
I'm sending it my filter
which comes from that
My Input text box.
I'm telling it I want the
output to include the
description of the topic.
So the output parameter let's
you say that you want more
than just that MID or basically
these fields here.
So ID, name, notable for, all
come by default, but using the
output parameter, you can say
I want description or I want
any of those other thousands
of properties that are
available in Freebase.
So it's a really flexible API
and we're just kind of
scratching the surface
in this demo.
And then once you get that data
in the call back, you can
really just iterate through
the results in that query.
So you'll see the top level here
is result and in the loop
here we're just going through
each item in that result and
inserting it into the DOM in our
web page or displaying it
in whichever app you're
working on.
So now I want to extend this
idea of collections that we've
built up to Geo Collections.
So looking for entities not
based on the explicit
relationships that they have
in the Knowledge Graph, but
based on proximity
geographically.
So this is something that we've
added just in the last
year to the Search API.
I think it's a pretty
cool feature.
And I really hope to see more
apps using this feature.
So let me show you a demo.
This is Google Maps and this is
a little view of Paris with
some markers on it they
correspond to tourist
attractions in Paris.
And so this is actually live.
This is using the
Freebase API.
And you'll see as I scroll
around the map, it's sending
off the search requests and
finding me different tourist
attractions based on where
I'm looking on the map.
And I can click on any of those
markers and it's going
to show me the name and the
description because, as you
saw in the last example, I have
the option to say output
the description as well.
But I could display any number
of properties here about one
of these tourist attractions.
So I think this is a really cool
way to take millions of
entities and put them in
context and make them
interesting for the user by
constraining it to only that
the ones that they care about
that specific point in time.
Just to show you here I can zoom
all the way out and go to
Rome instead.
Tempting the demo gods, here.
Once I get in close enough,
it should start pulling up
entities from Freebase.
So you can see this is a Roman
farm, Palazzo Farnese.
So it really is a massive
dataset at your fingertips.
And there are a lot of really
cool things that I think
people could do with this
in their application.
So here's what that API
request looks like.
Notice the filter is getting a
little bit more complicated
now, but it's still--
well at least to me-- it
reads left to right.
So we're saying match all of the
following constraints and
we want them to have to type
Tourist Attraction so not just
anything in Freebase that's Geo
coded because there could
be other things that are not
relevant in terms of tourism.
And then we have a more
complicated constraint over
here on the right hand side
which is it has to be within
5,000 feet of this latitude
and longitude.
And so you can change the radius
of that circle that
it's matching against.
You can change the
Geo coordinates.
As you saw in the example,
I was changing the Geo
coordinates dynamically based
on the center of the map.
So this query will find you
those tourist attractions
within 5,000 feet of
somewhere in Paris.
Here's what the code
looks like in
JavaScript with jQuery.
So you've seen a lot of
this stuff before.
The filter, the output,
iterating through the results,
and then just creating markers
with the Google Maps API and
pinning those results with
a name to the map.
I'm going to be uploading the
code for the full demo after
the talk and you can see all the
other stuff I did to get
the description in there,
but it's really not a
lot of extra code.
You can see here getting the
Geolocation, we're just going
into the output, getting the
Geolocation property, then the
location location Geolocation
property, and then the first
entry in there.
Now the last thing I
want to talk about
is topical web links.
And so there's a lot of
interesting things that you
can do with a Knowledge Graph
of 40 million entities and
having all those relationships
between them, but it becomes
even more interesting when
you can link out to
the rest of the web.
And so, as I showed you at the
very beginning on that Keys
tab in the Freebase, we have
foreign keys out to other
databases or links to
other websites.
So an entity on Freebase like
Jeff Bridges will have a
Freebase page but he might also
have a YouTube channel,
he might also have a page
on Google Play.
And so we try to link out to as
many of those as possible.
And we're continually adding
more of these foreign key
relationships out to
other data sources.
So let me show you how easy it
is to do something like that.
Just choose Jeff Bridges.
So this is actually an
unconstrained suggest box.
That's why you see all kinds of
different entities there.
And once I pick him, you'll see
the web links that we have
right now for Jeff Bridges
in Freebase.
There are actually more than
that, we have all the
different language versions of
Wikipedia, but for this demo,
I constrained them down
to this list.
And you would probably want to
do the same thing in your
application depending on which
sites you want to show.
And you can see different
entities are going to have
different types of links.
So if I click here, I
can go to Richard
Branson's Plus page.
So not only is that a way that
you can provide more
information to the users of
your application about the
entity that they're looking at,
but it's also a way that
you can tap into other APIs.
And I'm going to be doing a Code
Lab tomorrow afternoon
where I show how to use these
links into YouTube to do
really cool mashups between
the Freebase API and the
YouTube API.
So to do these topical links
queries, we're actually using
a different part of
the Freebase API
called the Topic API.
The Topic API you can think of
as a shortcut around the
Search API where all we're
interested in is one node in
the Graph, but everything there
is to know about that
node in the Graph.
And because we're asking for
everything there is know about
that node in the Graph,
we, again,
need some filter syntax.
So here we can say, just filter
it down to values from
the common topic social media
presence, which is like the
Twitter and Facebook links, or
just filter it down to a topic
equivalent web page, which is
things like Richard Branson's
homepage or things like that.
And in fact, we can add multiple
filter parameters on
the end of that too.
And so we can say, give us
both of those things, but
nothing else.
And this is what
it looks like.
It's another nested
JSON structure.
So we got the ID for the
entity at the top.
Then we have a dictionary
of all the
properties we asked for.
In this case, it was just
the one property.
And then within there, we
have an array of values.
Each value has a value.
The actual value that's stored
in the Graph, as well as, the
textual representation
of the Graph.
And so that may vary for
different types of values like
dates and times.
We also record the creator and
the timestamp of every fact in
the Freebase Knowledge Graph
so you can always see who
created what and when
it was created.
And then lastly, some of the
properties like name, as you
saw, get internationalized.
And so if there is a language
attached to that particular
value than the Lang property
will have that
language code in there.
So this is how easy it is to
do with jQuery, again.
We're just attaching
that Suggest
widget to an input field.
Once we get that MID back--
remember, I said it's
important to turn that keyword
search into an MID because
once you have it, you can call
the Topic API, like we are
here, and get structured data
about that specific entity
that you chose from
the Autosuggest.
And then once we have that data,
we can just loop through
that array of values for the web
links and display them on
the screen like I did.
So those were the five different
examples of what
we're doing with Freebase
and the Knowledge Graph.
There's a lot more and so I
encourage you to look at the
Freebase documentation.
But definitely we've seen a
lot of people using the
Autosuggest feature.
I know there are a couple
startups that are using the
Tagging feature.
You've seen collections of
entities in Google Search.
Geosearch is a really
exciting new feature
that we've just added.
And Topical Weblinks is a great
way to mashup Freebase
data with other APIs.
Here are more links just
to get you started.
All the APIs that I talked about
today, as well as the
different libraries that
let you use that code.
I also mentioned I have a Code
Lab tomorrow that's 2:00 to
4:00 in Room Three.
So bring your laptop.
We're going to be building
an app using
Freebase and YouTube APIs.
As well, I have office hours
tomorrow morning
from 9:00 to 11:00.
That's up on the third floor in
the Knowledge Graph booth.
So you can come and ask me
anything about Freebase or the
Knowledge Graph.
I'd be happy to hear about
what you're working on.
So thank you very much
for coming out.
Here's the link to the
slides online.
Here's how to contact
me online.
And I'd be happy to take any
questions if you'd like to
step up to the mic.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
I've got a quick question
for you, if I could.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: One of the things
you mentioned is it it's
possible to get an RDF
dump of Freebase.
Are there ways to get filtered
versions of that down?
For example, if we wanted just
an RDF dump of a particular
entity collection.
Or should we get the
whole thing and
then filter it ourselves?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Right now,
there's only one RDF dump.
So you have to download
the whole thing
and filter it yourself.
AUDIENCE: OK.
SHAWN SIMISTER: We have had a
number of people asking for
different sections of Freebase
as a data dump so we're
considering different ways to
do that but we haven't found
the right way to provide slices
of the data dump.
It is a pretty simple format.
So the RDF format that we use is
one triple per line, which
means you can kind of
grep over the file.
You don't need a specific RDF
parser if all you want to do
is filter out lines that
have a certain
type of data on them.
So that's sort of the best
way to handle that
use case right now.
But we're looking
for better ways.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have two
quick questions.
One, how big is the RDF dump,
like in megabytes, gigabytes?
Is there an estimate?
SHAWN SIMISTER: What is it?
It's around 15 gigabytes now.
And that's a zip file so when
you unzip it, it gets about
five times bigger.
So you need some disk
space to go over it.
Because of the format, like I
said, it's a text file that's
been gzipped with one triple
in the Graph per line.
You can actually use some tools
like gzip grep to go
through it without
unzipping it.
AUDIENCE: And also, I went to
the site and I couldn't figure
out how to get a list
of all the object
types or the node types.
SHAWN SIMISTER: OK.
AUDIENCE: Is there an API to get
that list or is there just
a publicly available?
I mean, I know it's on the front
page but that was only
like a subsidized list.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah.
So yeah, on the front page of
Freebase here, we've got a
list of all the categories
of schema that we have.
And then if you drill down into
one of those categories,
you'll see all the types.
So we don't have all types on
one page because there's
thousands of them.
But that's how you're able
to navigate them.
And then from there, you can
drill down into any one of
those types and see all
the properties that go
along with that type.
So that's how Freebase
is organized.
One more question at the back.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
In the JSON responses
I noticed there
was like a cost node--
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --I just had a
question, what was that?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah, that's
something that we just have in
there for debugging just
to monitor the
performance of the APIs.
AUDIENCE: So it's not like cost
in terms of monetary?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah.
The API is completely
free and we have no
plans to change that.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious
about equality.
So say, the popular actress Jane
Doe goes and gets married
and is now Jane Smith
and the entity
appears twice in Freebase.
I want to ask all of the movies
that Jane Doe or Jane
Smith or any name of that entity
appeared in, how does
Freebase handle that?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Changing
names is
actually not that difficult.
It happens quite a bit.
And because we have those unique
MIDs for each node in
the Graph--
AUDIENCE: But in multiple
sources.
It if the entity appears
twice, and I know
that they're equal.
Is there a way to
tell Freebase?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Right.
So that's a more difficult
case when we load two
authoritative sources and they
both have a Jane Doe.
And we kind of discover that
after the fact and we have to
reconcile them together.
So we have a number of tools for
matching them and noticing
when two entities share enough
properties that maybe it's
worthwhile for a human
to take a look at it.
And then we actually flag
them for a merge.
So actually anyone who logs
into Freebase can find
duplicate topics and flag
them for a merge.
Then they go into a queue
where they're reviewed.
And once they're reviewed,
there's a software process
that will do with the messy work
of merging them together.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yes.
And please, if you're willing
to help us out work through
that queue of duplicates,
it's a very noble duty.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I noticed you had a score factor
for entity types that
you get back.
How is that calculated?
Or what does it mean?
SHAWN SIMISTER: So the score on
the ranked list of results
is kind of an opaque number.
We don't give any guarantees
about you could store that in
your database and use
it a year later and
it would mean anything.
The only real guarantee is that
something that's more
relevant to your query will
have a higher number and
something that's less relevant
will have a lower number.
But yeah, it's based on a number
of things, either in
the Freebase Graph and in the
Knowledge Graph that we use to
rank those search results.
AUDIENCE: So for example, if I
have, let's say, Madonna and
it could be a single but it
could also be some other
personality, does the score mean
anything between the two?
Can I use it to sort?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah,
absolutely.
So the score of the result
should reflect the notability
of that entity.
So the Madonna that I think you
and I are both thinking
about right now is probably the
one that's going to have
the highest score.
AUDIENCE: And that's
based on what?
SHAWN SIMISTER: It's based on
where we've seen it in the
data that we pull from, so
Wikipedia and other sources,
as well as some other signals
that we look at internally.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: If you're developing a
schema in Freebase yourself,
does the key somehow support
that that gets conflated?
You're able to do the same
searches with the API on the
things that you're developing
sort of privately in Freebase?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah.
So anyone with an account can
create their own schema.
It goes under their
own name space.
So you'll have a user name and
your schema will all start
with slash user slash
your username and
then the schema key.
So no one can overwrite anyone
else's schema that way.
And then our mailing list has
an informal process of
promotion where you can kind
of call out your schema,
discuss it with people,
and say, what do you
think of this schema?
Do you think it's worth
promoting into one of those
common name spaces that
everyone can use?
But yeah, you can definitely
develop your own schema
without worrying about
trotting on
other people's data.
And anything that you
do on your own is
available through the APIs.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Is there a RDF notation or a
schema.org notation to help
you structure the data
from common websites?
SHAWN SIMISTER: It's something
we've been working on.
So the schema in Freebase tends
to be a little bit more
detailed, a little bit more
denormalized than schema.org.
And so we've taken a couple
cracks at doing a mapping
between those two schemas.
We don't have anything automated
where you could make
a Freebase request
and then just get
schema.org on the page.
But I think that would
be something
interesting to look into.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] tag
content on HTML to help you
directly from that
point of view?
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah.
Yeah.
I think that would
be a great idea.
AUDIENCE: And another thing,
do you rate the link or the
facts between entities or not?
SHAWN SIMISTER: I'm sorry.
Could you repeat that?
AUDIENCE: Do you rate
the links or the
facts between entities?
Is there a score?
SHAWN SIMISTER: There's no score
on the relationships
between entities.
So things are either true or
they're not in Freebase, or
they're a bug.
We don't have degrees of
truth in Freebase.
AUDIENCE: Two short questions.
SHAWN SIMISTER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
SHAWN SIMISTER: How do we manage
updates and how do we
make sure that the updates
are not garbage?
OK.
We've run out of time here, but
I can definitely answer
your question after this.
Thank you very much.